[Applaudissements]
championne sportive on les écoute c'est
la conférence de presse d'être sur des
huit c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je vais commencer par un
rapide rappel des faits comme vous le
savez hier soir lors de l'émission
touche pas à mon poste
cyril hanouna ici présents à disputer un
match de ping pong contre l'animateur de
télévision stéphane plaza en cas de
défaite
cyril s'était engagé à ne pas présenter
l'émission touche pas à mon poste et ce
pendant deux semaines malheureusement
cyril a perdu cette rencontre
nous allons maintenant passer aux
questions est elle donnée au ping pong
magazine est ce que vous allez vous
retirer définitivement du milieu du
tennis de table pour l'instant et aucune
décision qui est prise c'est sûr qu'on
va en parler avec avec les entraîneurs
avec avec le staff que c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui voilà je suis pas don
j'ai pas de motivation pour aller faire
ou un tennis de table ou un jeu carrière
bilboquet outre aux sports de balle à
proprement parler je viens parce que
pour canal+
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pendant
ces deux semaines d'absence du char à
voile normalement
je me suis inscrit dans un stage de char
à voile à pendant deux semaines mais
aujourd'hui voilà aujourd'hui je suis
dans l'inconnu coup j'ai pris un gros
coup sur la tête
et aujourd'hui il faut que faut que
j'aille de la presse qu'un toniutti et
tpms et journal passion immobilier est
ce que stéphane plaza est le meilleur
joueur de ping pong au monde
je sais pas si c'est le meilleur joueur
ou pas ce que je sais aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il a gagné mais aujourd'hui on a des
choses qui nous font douter je crois
xavier gandon et moi même et ce monsieur
qu'on va vous présenter dans un instant
de sa bonne foi
sur ce match je crois que le mieux c'est
de laisser la parole à l'expert si vous
présente donc c'est eddy ban ping pong
le président de la fédération tunisienne
de pinto bonsoir je me présente à adébem
ping pong
j'étais présenté hier soir monsieur
stéphane placenta à trish à deux
reprises durant le match
première preuve regardez cet extrait
play et asseoir 4 attention au
lave-linge ou shooter joujou grave
comme vous l'avez vu ce n'était pas très
fan trois ans c'était monsieur ang lee
lemoine joueurs chinois de tennis de
table professionnel média pire encore
j'ai avec moi c'est bon bout avec vous
si vous avez donc et cela j'ai avec moi
les analyses d'urines de monsieur
hanouna et de monsieur présent alors
monsieur hanouna comme vous le constatez
c'est seulement ça va s'excuser comme
vous pouvez le constater tout semble
normal et celle de monsieur stéphane
plaza comme vous le voyez il ya plein de
produits dopants merci regardez comme
vous allez le constater
voilà je pense que la preuve est faite
que monsieur pazza à tricher monsieur
ben ping pong sur la base de ces preuves
irréfutables du dopage de monsieur plaza
pouvez vous nous confirmer que nous
pouvons déclarer annulé annulé le match
qui s'est déroulé hier soir
tout à fait je valide ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer que dans ces conditions
cyril hanouna peut reprendre la
présentation de l'émission tout à fait
il que débute tout de suite cyril je
voudrais quand même dire quelque chose
au nom de davis
oui c'est qu'il n'en reste pas moins que
tu as perdu sept partis hier c'est un
échec et je pense qu'ils devraient avoir
une compensation et vis-à-vis de la
chaîne et vis-à-vis du public écoutez je
pense qu'on en parle
on va en parler tout de suite sur le
plateau avec le directeur général et on
va vous donner encore tous les tenants
et les aboutissants de cette affaire
on arrive mathieu de lambeaux à vous les
studios à vous cognacq jay merci
monsieur benoit là